بعقبه وتلاشيف راسي تحقيق اختراق يسلم
العام 2022 الايراني ودائعه للعام الجديد
في طهران احتجاجات داخليه عقوبات اوروبيه
اساسها القنا ضد المحتجين وارتكاسه مفاوضه
فيينا التي شكلت ريهانا كبيرا على الخروج
من عنق زجاجه الازمه الاقتصاديه
حمل في هذا السياق مسؤوليه مراوحه
المفاوضات النوويه للسلطات الايرانيه وفق
موقع اجاده ايران مشيرا الى ان طهران قتلت
حدود العوده السريعه الى الاتفاق النووي
بسبب رفضها المتكرر للمقترحات المعروضه
عليها خلال العامين الماضيين لكن بالنسبه
الى المسؤولين الايرانيين فلديهم رؤيه
سياسيه مختلفه عبر عنها في اكثر من مناسبه
وزير الخارجيه حسين امير عبد هيا الفرصه
سامحه لاتخاذ الخطوات النهائيه لاحياء
الاتفاق النووي لكنها لن تبقى كذلك للابد
لكن خلف تعثر حقائق فرضتها عوامل بعضها
قديم واساسي وبعضها الاخر مستجد في
العوامل القديمه اصرار ايران على غلق ملف
التحقيق باثر اليورانيوم في عده مواقع
نوويه يقابله اصرار من الوكاله الدوليه
بمواصله التحقيق وانتظار اجوبه واضحه من
منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه في العناصر
الجديده انزلاق ايران او تورطها في تسليح
روسيا بالمسيرات في حربها على اوكرانيا
ايضا برز موقف امريكي جديد نقل الاولويه
من مفاوضات ذي اننا الى احتجاجات ايران
واشنط ستركز جهودها على امدادات الاسلحه
الايرانيه الى روسيا وعلى دعم المتظاهرين
بدلا من التركيز على المحادثات النوويه
المعطله التي لا نعرف فائدتها
حاله عدم يقين سياسي تترافق مع تازم
الاقتصاديا ضاغط وتدفع الاحتجاجات
والاضرابات الى التحول الى مشهد دائم في
المدن الايرانيه طالب تبدا بشعارات الحريه
والانتفاضه على النظام وتمر بالتضخم
والوظائف والاجور كالملف النووي تبقى
معلقه بلا اجابات او معالجات مستدامه